Gözden geçirme: Eren Gokce
Öğretmenlik hayatımın 15. yılına girdim
ve bu beni çok heyecanlandırıyor.
On beş yıldır, on sekiz aydan itibaren
bütün yaş gruplarıyla
çalışma şansım oldu
ve umuyorum ki daha uzun yıllar
bu alandaki çalışmalarıma devam edeceğim.
Ama şimdi,
biraz geriye gitmek istiyorum.
Tam 35 yıl kadar geriye.
35 yıl öncesi şurası olsun mesela.
Fotoğrafta gördüğünüz gibi
ben, Kemal Sunal'ın kızı olarak
dünyaya geldim
(Alkış)
Bu alkışlar, bir kere daha
az sonra anlatacağım konuyu
çok güzel özetledi, doğruladı.
Tabii ki din, dil, ırk, cinsiyet
meslek ayrımı olmadan
Türkiye'nin bu kadar çok
sevdiği bir insanın
sadece sanatçı demiyorum,
"bir insanın"
çocuğu olarak dünyaya gelmek
muhteşem bir şey.
Bunu tabii ki kabul ediyorum
ve çok gurur duyarak
küçüklüğümden beri yaşıyorum.
Fakat
tabii ki siz de takdir edersiniz ki
bunun yanında getirdiği
bazı sorumluluklar,
bazı zorluklar ve bazı dezantajlar da var.
Bunlardan en bariz olanı
ve paylaşmak istediğim şu:
Belki ailemden değil,
yakın çevrem veya akrabalarımdan değil
ama
Kemal Sunal'ın sevenlerinden
çok beklentiler oldu.
Küçüklüğümden beri, hâlâ da oluyor.
Bir çeşit psikolojik baskı da diyebiliriz.
Yaptığın bir hareketle
babana layık oldun, olmadın.
Bir yere gittin,
babasına layık oldu, olmadı.
Bir şey söyledi,
layık oldu, olmadı.
Bunun dışında bir de
meslek seçimi var tabii.
Herkes
genlerden dolayı sanırım
oyuncu olmamı bekledi.
Ya da sinemayla alakalı,
veya sanatla alakalı
bir alanda çalışmamı bekledi,
diye düşünüyorum.
Hâlâ bir mesleğimi sorduğunda
"Eğitimciyim" veya "Öğretmenim" dediğimde,
yüzünde bir hayal kırıklığı.
Hele ilk mezun olup
geldiğim zamanlarda keşke görseydiniz.
"Ezo sen ne yaptın?"
"Neler yapıyorsun?"
Ben de heyecanla "Öğretmenim" diyorum,
gururla, gözlerimin içi parlıyor.
Çünkü zannediyorum ki öğretmenlik
kutsal bir meslek,
herkes benimle gurur duyacak,
çok hoşlarına gidecek.
(Alkış)
Fakat benim için hiç de öyle olmadı.
Normal bir ailede
biri öğretmen çıktığında müthiş bir şey.
Ben...
Asla.
Şöyle bir hayal kırıklığı suratı
[Gösteriyor]
Ve şunu diyen oldu
"Olsun."
[Gülüyor]
Bunu dediler.
Gözümün içine baka baka dediler.
O zamanlar 20-21 yaşlarındayım.
En çarpıcı başka bir örneği
daha vermek istiyorum
"Ezo sen ne yapıyorsun?
"Nasıl gidiyor?"
Bir ilkokul arkadaşıma karşılaşmıştım.
Anlatıyorum heyecanlı heyecanlı
"Çocuk atölyem var"
"Böyle çalışıyorum, şöyle yapıyorum"
"Çocuklar harika, çok mutluyum." falan
Durdu durdu,
o da yine hayal kırıklığı ifadesiyle
"Ezo ya, çocuklarla nereye kadar"
dedi bana.
Bunu dedi.
Ve en son yaşadığım olaya geliyorum.
Hâlâ kabullenemedi insanlar,
bakın on beş yıl diyorum.
Belli ki kararlıyım artık,
istikrarlı gidiyorum, değil mi?
Geçen hafta olan bir şeyi
söylemek istiyorum şimdi
Bir gazeteci fotoğrafımı yayınladı.
Altında şu yazıyor:
"Ezo Sunal: Oyunculuğa mesafeli eğitimci"
(Gülüşmeler)
Bakın, herkes eğitimci olabilir
ama oyunculuğa mesafeli eğitimci
olmayı hak etmek için
ne yaptım inanın hiç haberim yok.
Bunu bir gazeteci yazdı,
aile dostu falan değil.
Her neyse,
dedim ya, ailemle hep gurur duydum.
Çünkü çok sevgi dolu bir ortamda büyüdüm
ve bu baskının yarısını bile
ailemden, yakın çevremden
ve akrabalarımdan görmedim.
Onlar benim hep hayatta mutlu olmamı,
kendi istediğim işi yapmamı
ve en önemlisi de
kendi tutkumu,
vatana millete hayırlı olacağım
işi bulmamı istediler
ve hep desteklediler.
Ben de şuna karar verdim:
"Benim, kendi oyun alanımı bulmam lazım."
İşte benim oyun alanım burası olsun.
[Durduğu yeri gösteriyor]
Kendim tutkuyla yapacağım
bir iş bulmam lazım
Kendimi en iyi ifade edeceğim
alanı bulmam lazım.
Ve bu, öğretmenlik oluverdi.
'98 yılında annemin açtığı
anaokulu sayesinde
ben çocukları çok sevdiğimi,
onlarla bir ömür
hiç yaşlanmayarak, hep mutlu olarak
yaşayabileceğimi gördüm.
İlk gün bir sınıfın kapısını çaldım,
okul açıldıktan sonra.
İçeri girdim
"Şişt" dedi bir çocuk bana
"Noldu?" dedim
Korktum yani bir an
yanlış bir şey yapmışım gibi.
Kucağında bir bebek sallıyor
"Bebek uyuyor" dedi.
Bebek falan yok tabii
ama var aslında.
"Peki, pardon." dedim
Devam edemedim orda,
daha ben de çocuğum
ne yapacağımı bilmiyorum, çıktım.
Bir sonraki sınıfa gittim
Tık tık tık, kapıyı tıkladım,
girdim başka bir çocuk
pelerin gibi bir şey bağlamış sırtına
ama pelerin değil.
Artık materyel çok kullanıyoruz okulda.
Böyle bir ispanyol etek gibi,
kırmızı,
yoğun dalgalı falan bir şey
boynunda bağlı.
Zıplıyor zıplıyor duruyor.
"Peki..." dedim
muhabbet de etmek istiyorum
"Sen ne yapıyorsun?" dedim.
"Ben Süperman'im" dedi
Gayet böyle gururlu
ve kendinden emin bir tavırla.
"Çok güzel peki uçabiliyor musun" dedim
Böyle bir sıkıntılandı, sıkıntı çöktü
"Ya uçuyorum ama hemen düşüyorum." dedi
Bu bakış açısı beni tavladı o an.
Dedim ki "Ben hayatımın geri kalanında
böyle devam etmek istiyorum"
Çünkü "Uçamam" demedi,
"Uçuyorum" dedi
"Sadece biraz daha çalışmam gerekiyor."
İşte bu bakış açısı aslında,
büyürken unuttuğumuz şeyleri hatırlatan
çok çarpıcı bir tokat gibi geldi bana.
Ve sonra
kendimi bu işe adadım.
Birçok okula gittim,
farklı ülkelerde keşfettim
kendi öğretmenlerimi düşündüm
Bazıları bana nasıl öğretmen olunmaması
gerektiğini gösterdi
Bazıları da tam olarak
bu mesleği seçmeme sebep oldu.
Bunlardan en önemlisi de,
benim için en değerlisi
Doug Goodkin isimli bir ustamdır.
Onun sayesinde ben
"Orff Schulwerk" eğitimini keşfettim.
Orff Schulwerk
Ünlü Alman besteci Carl Orff'un
eğitime kazandırdığı bir yaklaşım.
Temelinde hareketi ritm ve müzik,
en önemlisi de oyun var.
Bu beni çok cezbetti.
Çünkü ben öğretmenleri gözlemlerken
hep şunu fark ettim.
Öğretmenlik, aslında tembelleşmeye
en müsait meslek.
Ne kadar ironik değil mi?
Yani, öğretmenlik diyoruz.
Öğretmen deyince akla ne gelir?
"Çalışkan, öğrencilerini seven,
öğretmeyi seven"
Ama bir o kadar da
tembelleşmeye en, en, en müsait meslek
Çünkü bir alan seçiyorsunuz
o bölümü kazandığınız için
veya aile zorladığı için
veya ilginiz olduğu için -şanslıysanız-
O bölümde öğretmen oluyorsunuz.
Sonra her yıl aynı şeyi
aynı yaş grubuna öğrete öğrete...
aslında bir tembellik çöküyor.
Bu bana olsun istemedim,
çünkü bu beni tatmin etmeyecek
bir öğretmen olarak.
Ben daha fazlasını nasıl yapablirim
diye araştırdım.
Ve Orff Schulwerk beni bu yüzden
hep cezbetti.
Çünkü müzik, çok kuvvetli bir araç.
Müzik, evrensel olarak herkesin sevdiği
aynı dili konuşmasak bile,
aynı yaşta olmasak bile
aynı deneyimleri yaşamamış olsak bile
hepimizi ortak noktada buluşturabilen
en güçlü araçlardan biri.
O yüzden de kendime müziği seçtim.
Ama bir sorun vardı
Ben ortaokulda müzikte hiç iyi değildim,
yani hep zayıf notlar gelirdi
hatta 1 bile aldım
Müzikten 1 alan kaç kişi
vardır ortaokulda?
Aldım.
Onu da başardım.
Ama sonra bu beni yıldırmadı
dediğim gibi Orff Schulwerk eğitimlerine
gitmeye başladım,
"Orff Yaklaşımları" olarak
çevriliyor Türkçesi
ve şunu gördüm.
Herkesin kendini sanatsal olarak
ifade etme becerisi var.
Sadece büyürken,
eğitim yaklaşımları ve karşılaştığımız
öğretmenler, okullar
bunu biraz geri planda bıraktığı için
oyun oynamayı ve sanatın içinde olmayı
kendimizi ifade etme yolları araştırmayı
unutuyoruz ve bırakıyoruz.
Ben unutmak istemedim,
unutturmak istemedim
ve öğretmen olarak en büyük
görevlerimizden birinin de
bu olduğunu düşünüyorum.
Şimdi size
bir dersimden fotoğraf
göstermek istiyorum.
Bir tane davul var ortada,
değil mi ne kadar basit bir araç?
Ve elimizde de birer tane baget var.
Bilmiyorum, yüz ifademi
seçebiliyor musunuz uzaktan?
Çok heyecanlıyım.
Çok çok heyecanlıyım,
çünkü bütün çocuklar da öyle.
Siz neye inanırsanız
onlar da hemen inanıyor.
Ve dünden razılar
eğlenmeye, iyi vakit geçirmeye,
oyun oynamaya dünden razılar.
Ama yetişkinleri biraz daha
ikna etmek gerekiyor, o ayrı.
Burada şunu gördüm ben
"Tamam, tutkumu buldum.
Ben bu işi yaparım"
İlk önce sevdiğim bir şey buldum
Sonra bunu yapabiliyor muyum?
Tabii bu da önemli.
Her şeyi çok severiz ama yapamayabiliriz.
İyi yapıyor olabileceğim şeyi
seçtiğimden emin oldum.
Ve bir öğretmen olarak
şuna hep dikkat etmek
gerektiğini düşündüm.
Bakın.
Mesela bu bizim orkestramız
Orff aletleri dediğimiz
ksilofon, metalofon
beden yakın vurmalı çalgıları kullanıyoruz
ki ilk önce
keman, piyano veya gitar gibi
eline aldığında ses çıkarmaktan
korkmadıkları enstrümanlar olsun
ilk karşılaştıkları.
Hemen ses çıkarsın,
kendini ifade etme aracı
olarak kullansın müzik aletini.
O yüzden de bu şekilde
bedene yakın vurmalı çalgılarla
başlamak en güzeli.
Ve gördüğünüz gibi
biz öğretmenler de, yetişkinler de
orkestranın bir parçasıyız.
Bütünün bir parçasıyız.
Onların önünde değiliz,
ne yapmaları gerektiğini söylemiyoruz.
Biz de o orkestranın bir parçasıyız.
Bizim de bir bölümümüz var
ve herkes kendi bölümünü çalıyor.
Bu neden önemli?
Çünkü, bu orkestra kurulana kadar,
bu bir süreç,
ilk önce dans ederek başlıyoruz,
bedenimizi keşfediyoruz.
Daha sonra müziği dinlemeyi öğreniyoruz.
Daha sonra müzik aletleriyle tanışıyoruz
ve o da bir süreç.
Müzik aletlerine saygı duymayı ve
onları nasıl kullanacağımızı öğreniyoruz.
Bu bir kaynaşma süreci.
Daha sonra çocuklara bir şarkı öğretiliyor
ve müziğin istedikleri bölümlerinde
çalmaları için teşvik ediyoruz.
Bu tabii ki bir günde olmuyor.
Bazen bir ay, bazen iki ay,
bazen üç ay.
Her çocukta farklı.
Ama ben bu güne kadar hiçbir çocuğu
zorlamadım enstrüman başına oturtmak için.
Önemli olan ayrıntı da bu.
Zaten siz bir şeyi
çok severek yaptığınızda
çocuklar için önemli olan o,
yetişkinler için
hep deriz ya "Rol model"--
tutkuyla bir şeyi yaptığınızda
o ilgi çekiyor.
O diyor ki çocuğa,
"Bak ne kadar keyif alıyor bu işten,
ben de bir deneyeyim."
"Ben de keyif alabilirim belki."
Onu aşıladıktan sonrası zaten
inanın akıyor.
Ve hepsini böyle ders aralarında
çalışırken buluyorum.
Bu yaş grubu mesela 5 yaşında.
Daha sonra kendi bölümlerini seçiyorlar,
ve artık bir orkestrayız.
Ondan sonra artık zaten benim
müdahale etmeme hiç gerek bile kalmıyor.
Bu örneği neden göstermek istedim?
Hani diyorum ya,
"Öğretmenlik, geleceğe şekil veren meslek"
Bir çocuğa, bir şeyi başarmanın,
tamamlamanın hazzını
yaşatmazsak eğer
ilerde aslında hayatından çok
keyif almayı bilmeyen
bir bireye dönüşme ihtimali çok yüksek.
Bu yüzden de
bir şey için çalışıp, uğraşıp
ona zaman ayırıp
başarıp
bunu başkalarıyla paylaşması
ilerde yapacağı herhangi bir şeyde
aslında her şeyde o hazzı
arayacak demek.
Bence öğretmenlerin
ilk hedefi bu olmalı.
O hazzı öğrencilerine yaşatmak.
Coğrafya, matematik, müzik, İngilizce...
Konular, araç olduğunu düşünüyorum.
Bizim temel hedefimizin öğretmen olarak
kesinlikle insanlara
bir işi başarmak için
önce çalışmamız gerekiyor,
motive olmamız gerekiyor
ve bunu yaptığımızda da
mutlaka bu işten keyif alacağız.
Başkalarını etkilemek için değil.
Önce kendimiz için.
Bunu deneyimleyen bir çocuk
zaten ilerdeki yaşantısında
hem özel hayatında
hem de bence iş hayatında
mutlu olacaktır.
Ve mutluluk en büyük başarıdır
diye düşünüyorum.
Burada da minik bir video örneği var.
Bakın, dikkatli bakarsanız benim...
küçük köpeğim Samba da
onların arasında.
İşte böyle olmalı
bence öğrenme ortamı.
Köpek, çocuk, çoluk...
Öğretmen yanlarında.
Dinleyelim, bakalım
ne çalıyorlar, nasıl çalıyorlar.
Yüz ifadelerine de dikkat ederek
dinlemenizi öneriyorum.
[Müzik çalıyor]
Evet
Gördüğünüz gibi
işlerini çok ciddiye alıyorlar.
Yüz ifadelerine bakarsanız
Hiçbirine "Dur" "Sus" diyen yok
veya "Öyle değil, böyle yapacaksın!"
Bazı öğretmenler yıl sonu gösterileri--
o da başka bir konu
başka zaman konuşuruz--
o yıl sonu gösterileri güzel çıksın diye
çocukları çok mutsuz ediyorlar.
Aslında bakın, hiç gerek yok.
Sadece sevdirmek,
ciddiye aldırmak yeterli.
Ve bu da ancak
eğer siz yaptığınız şeye inanırsanız
karşı tarafa geçiyor diye düşünüyorum.
Şimdi diğer Ezo'ya geçecek olursak
dediğim gibi ailenin desteği
birinci sırada yer alıyor.
Alienin repütasyonu
iyi de olabilir, kötü de
ama bu bizim bahanemiz olmamalı.
En büyük görevimiz bu hayatta
kendi yolculuğumuzu bulmamız
diye düşünüyorum.
Bunun dışında
dediğim gibi ben
kendi tutkumu buldum
bu alanda çalışmayı çok seviyorum
ve bu alandaki çalışmalarımı
diğer kişilerle
öğretmenlerle ve çocuklarla
paylaşmayı çok seviyorum.
Çünkü
çocukların gözünde siz
hiç kimsesiniz aslında ilk bakışta.
Ön yargıları yok.
Beklentileri yok.
Herhangi bir yargılama
veya eleştirme durumları yok.
Sadece onları sevmeniz
ve orada olmak istemeniz
çocuklar için yeterli.
Sizi sevmeleri ve
kabul etmeleri için yeterli.
Ve bu beni çok büyüleyen bir şey.
O yüzden de onlardan kopamıyorum sanırım.
Dediğim gibi
bütün öğretmenlerin ilk hedefi
geleceğe şekil verdiklerini unutmamaları
en önemlisi de
çocuklara ilk sırada sevgiyi,
ondan sonra da bir işi başarmanın hazzını
yaşatmaları gerektiğini düşünüyorum.
Ve bunu ancak hep birlikte
hep bareber
aynı dili konuşarak yapabiliriz
diye düşünüyorum.
Teşekkür ederim.
(Alkış)